so far in the course we've talked about
multitask learning and meta learning for
supervised learning uh and now we're
going to start talking about
reinforcement learning which introduces
a number of really interesting
challenges and and also opportunities to
do better when you're trying to learn
multiple tasks and
i learn across tasks
uh and the first lecture on
reinforcement learning and multitask
reinforcement learning will be uh by
carl so i'll let
carl take it away
um right welcome everybody um
so um thanks chelsea for the
introduction and
today we'll be talking about
reinforcement learning it will be mostly
a primer
but we'll also talk a little bit about
multitask and goal condition around
so this is the first lecture that i'm
giving in this course so um i'd like to
do a little introduction
my name is carol hausmann
i come from a country in europe called
poland that is right here
and i'm not a native english speaker as
you can probably tell by now
so please please let me know if there is
something that you don't understand i
really care about making sure that
everything i
say and explain is understand this is
understood by all of you um so please
raise your hand in chat
raise your hand or just erase something
in the chat and i'll try to get back to
you as soon as i see it
um
if there is something that you should
know about me is that i really like
robots um and i've been working on
robots for quite some time now so um
during the classes that i'll be giving
the material might be skewed a little
bit towards that application
also i studied classical robotics first
where i was working on
a concept called interactive perception
where basically we're trying to control
the robots in a way that will make the
perception of for the robots a little
bit easier
and while i was doing this i remember
going to a talk that was given by a
student at that point of sergey levin
about deep reinforcement learning and i
got completely fascinated by it um i
kind of thought that this is the right
way of doing things and the right way of
solving things that i was actually
working on and that eliminates these
boundaries between control and
perception and considers them as one
interconnected problem um so after that
part i got very fascinated and i
completely switched my phd topic and
started working on deep reinforcement
learning and continue working on it ever
since
um so if i have any small piece of
advice to you is if you find something
like this that
you know you really like and you're
really fascinated by it uh i'd recommend
to to following that path because uh can
be very rewarding
um
and then lastly i'm also a research
scientist at uh robotics at google which
is part of google brain
and
that's where we try to apply some of the
algorithms that we'll be learning about
today and
during other lectures um we try to apply
them to real robots at scale
so i'll try to bring that perspective a
little bit more um throughout the
lectures so that you can see how some of
these algorithms work in practice
all right um so with that um
let's first start with uh why should we
care why should we focus on
reinforcement learning in general
and i would like to pose a question to
you um to think about can you think of
an action and a fully isolated action
that doesn't affect the future and what
i mean by that is an action that doesn't
have any long-term consequences so there
is the immediate consequence when you
perform that action in the real world
but um are there any actions that don't
have long-term consequences
and um i encourage you to think a little
bit about this but
in the meantime i think it's i i'd like
to answer that i think it's really
really hard
um so even
um you know like an action that seems
very meaningless like for example me
tapping my fingers right now
um it seems that it doesn't have any
influence in the future but it might be
that because i tapped my fingers right
now i exerted so much energy
or i served more energy than i would
that i uh would have if i didn't tap
them
and because of that later on during the
day i will need um you know maybe a nap
to um to get my energy back
and in particular i would like to show
you one experiment that kind of tries to
exemplify this concept and this is an
experiment
that is often shown in things such as
chaos theory or butterfly effect i
encourage you to look some of these up
and uh basically it shows an uh double
pendulum that starts from more or less
the same initial condition so you can
see six different pendulums right here
these are this is the same uh pendulum
just uh repeated six times
and you can see that there's a human
hand that starts the experiment but from
what we can tell it basically looks
exactly the same in for in all of these
pictures
and now we start the experiment we let
the pendulum go
and this is recorded in slow motion and
you can see that initially all of the
pendulums behave exactly the same
right so they're indistinguishable even
at this point
however over time you will be able to
tell that all of them perform completely
different motions and they're in
completely different positions
and this is one of the statements of
chaos theory that states that even in a
fully deterministic world or in a world
that is
governed by deterministic equations
um because of the fact that we can't
really uh disambiguate the initial
conditions we always have to round it up
um to to you know certain
number that we can actually uh we can we
can actually
do the real experiments on uh because of
that initial state that is a little bit
different and the initial action that is
also a little bit different the final
effects will be actually random even
though the entire world is governed by
uh even if we assume that the entire
world is governed by uh deterministic
equations
so there is actually one example of an
action that does not affect the future
and this is how we model things in
supervised learning so in supervised
learning we make certain decision and
that decision could be for example on
what's in the image in the object
recognition case we're given an image we
have to say um is there a cat in the
image and we'll perform the decision and
we pretend that that decision has no
consequences beyond that one action that
we just did
so this seems a little this this looks
like a very small isolated world that
doesn't really um
doesn't really adhere to how the the
real world
real world works
so reinforcement learning tries to tries
to deal with this problem and tries to
model the the fact that every decision
we make is actually as we can actually
have consequences long term
um and it copes with the problem of
sequential decision making so how the
decisions that we make now will
influence the future and how it will
influence our future decisions
and because of that because it's such a
real world kind of concept it has many
common applications
um some of which we'll talk about such
as robotics a language and dialogue
systems autonomous driving where your
actions will influence other agents
actions and because of that it will
influence your actions again as well as
business operations and finance
so basically most deployed machine
learning systems have to deal with that
sequential decision making aspect
and also
i think we can we can argue that the
fact that we can make sequential
decisions is one of the key aspects of
of intelligence
right so the plan for this lecture
would be as following uh first we'll get
familiar with the multi-task
reinforcement learning problem then
we'll discuss one way to solve that
problem by using the policy gradient
method
and we'll learn about their multi-task
counterparts as well and we'll talk a
little bit about queue learning which
should be mostly a review based on the
the lectures that you that you've taken
previously
um and then we'll talk about
multitasking learning as well
all right so let's let's start with
multitask url
um so first let's introduce some
terminology so that we can all operate
on on the same terms this should be
mostly i think review for most of you so
we'll go over this quickly um so if we
start from an object recognition a
supervised learning pipeline it might
look some something like this where we
are given an image uh as an input then
that image is propagated through some
neural network a convolutional network
for example and at the end of that
network we're trying to classify what's
in that image whether it's tiger or
another animal
one change that we'll make in the
reinforcement learning scenario is that
we'll sub index all of the things by
time step t
right so we'll observe an image on a
certain observe at a certain time step
team that image will then be propagated
for our neural network and then we'll
output some kind of action also at the
same time step
now that action will influence our next
observation so we'll then get our next
observation ot plus one and then we'll
need to perform another action based on
that observation
also as we just said our actions are
real actions in the real world so we no
longer have to decide what's in the
image but we actually have to do
something about it so when we are given
an image of a tiger we for example have
three options we can run away ignore or
pet it and all of these will influence
how the world is going to propagate from
now on
all right so to describe this notation
um o of t would uh
uh denote observation at time step t
a t is an action that we perform on the
time step
and uh and then we will describe um a
policy pi theta
or pi theta
that gives us the probability of action
given the observation as the policy so
this is this is the policy that we'll
use to uh to know how to act in a given
situation
in addition to this we'll have um st
which we'll call state and we'll get
back to it in a second
and then we also have a fully observed
version of a policy which is pi theta
that gives us actions given the current
state
so let's talk a little bit about that um
state versus observation problem
and um
i'd like to bring up an
example from philosophy um this is known
as uh plato's cave
um where plato had had the idea that uh
we as humans are captured in um in a
little cave
um and it takes
quite long to for us to get us to get
out of that cave and there's like a
whole complex philosophy behind it but
the basic idea is that we are captured
in that cave and we don't really get to
observe the true nature of things but
instead we just see the reflections of
them
right so um in particular
uh what you can see right here there's a
god right here that is holding the true
object that we don't get to see
this is a human this is us sitting in
the cave and there's this big fire
behind us that we also don't get to see
and we only get to see the shadow of the
true object that is projected onto onto
the wall
all right so now
using that that metaphor the true nature
of objects is the state that we don't
get to observe very often
and then the the reflection that we get
to see is the observation
right so the observations might be
incomplete it might not have all the
necessary information for us to be able
to perform the right decision
but the state has everything that we
would ever need to know how to act
all right so maybe a more practical
example would look some like something
like that
uh we're looking at an at an image and
that image is an observation and we have
to make a decision based on that but in
order to make that decision we actually
might want to know a little bit more
that's what's what that's what in the
image so for example the positions of
the objects as well as their velocities
so the state should have all the
information that we would that we would
need to make a decision
and the observation can be actually
quite incomplete so for example there
could be an occlusion there could be a
car in front of us and because of
because of that we don't even get to see
the cheetah
and we'll talk about that the problem of
not being able to observe everything a
little bit later too
all right so this is our um terminology
um so let's try to think how we could
how we could find a policy
right so one way we can do this is to
take the knowledge that we that we have
from supervised learning scenario and
try to apply directly to this problem
and this is what we'll be referring to
as imitation learning
so in this case we have that image that
goes through the network outputs actions
um and the images that we want to focus
on in particular are images that are
coming from a camera that was installed
on a car
and we'll be recording actions of humans
that were actually driving these cars
and this was research done at nvidia by
abuyarski at all
in a system called alvin where they
basically had human truck drivers
driving their cars as usual and they
would record all the observations all
the images that the car would see and
the corresponding actions of the human
drivers would
take so now what we could do is we could
just store all of these and compose a
big training data set
and then use supervised learning to um
to train our policy based on that
so if we did that at the end we'll get
our policy pi theta
um so this is this is one way how we how
we could do this
um
[Music]
sorry one second um so the question is
are there any problems with that so are
there any problems with imitation
learning with the way how it was done
for example by the folks at nvidia
and um
if anybody has any ideas please write in
chat or raise your hand
right okay
problems might occur in in a new
environment our decisions are
independent
we are only capturing observations not
for the observed state it's not scalable
all right no idea if a wrong decision is
made yes so one of the problems is
i think these are all really good
answers one of the problems is um
related to something that we saw before
with that with the double pendulum so um
if there is some error and we don't fit
our actions perfectly then the air will
accumulate and we'll get into a state
that we that we haven't seen any data
so
for example the cards will start
deviating and because we're only
collecting the the the data of drivers
driving correctly we wouldn't know how
to behave or we are getting off the
road all right great
um
so reinforcement learning is trying to
model this problem um in a in a
more holistic way
so in this case we we have to have some
kind of way of of um we need to have
some utility that we want to optimize
for so before we could just say let's
just try to optimize our policies such
as we repeat the actions that the humans
would take
in this case we have to optimize for
something else
and this is where reward functions come
in handy
so reward function would be something
that will allow us to disambiguate which
actions are better and which ones are
worse
the reward function would be dependent
on the state and the action
and it will have a scalar value that
we'll try to optimize
so in the case of of driving that we
that we just talked about a high reward
might correspond to us driving safely
and smoothly on the road and the low
reward will be will correspond to an
accident for example
and all of these components so the state
the action as well as the reward
function that depends on the current
state in action as well as the
transition dynamics which tell us the
probability of the next day the given my
current state and the action that i just
took
defined so-called the markov decision
process
and this is the framework that we'll be
operating in
[Music]
all right so let's talk a little bit
more about that framework and the goal
of reinforcement learning
so our goal is to find the parameters
theta of the policy pi theta
and that policy takes observations as
inputs
and outputs actions
these these observations actually are
result of some underlying state that we
don't get to see
and then that that state together with
our action uh produced the next state
according to this transition dynamics
the probability of s prime given s comma
a
that results in the next state which
then produces the next observation which
is then fed into our policy and we get
to reduce the action
all right so this corresponds to a
probabilistic graphical model that looks
more or less like this
where we have various connections here
so for example the observation the
connection between the observation and
action is our policy pi theta
and the connection between the current
state and action that connects these two
to the next state is our transition
dynamics p of s t plus one given s t and
a t
so there is an important thing to note
here which is that um if you look at
this probabilistic graphical model
um
the
probability of the current state only
depends on the next state only depends
on the current state and the current
action it's completely independent of
the states before that and the actions
before that
and this is known as the markov property
so basically what
um what we mean by that
is something
[Music]
something like that let me just try to
draw on this
um
so
we see that given
our s2
and a2
um s3 is is known and this is
conditionally independent
of s1 for example so this connection is
not there
right
in addition to this which we'll learn a
little bit later in the course
there's one
other random variable here which is
dependent on the current state in action
and this is this is the optimality
variable
let's big let's call it big o one
and this is related to the reward
function at the time step so this is a
reward of state given state one and
action one
right
and that optimality variable or that
reward is also conditionally independent
of the previous state
it's only dependent on the current state
and the current action so we can also
draw it
draw it right here state an action this
will be our o2
and now given s2 and a2
that's everything we we need to know um
uh to know about the um
to know about the reward and this is
conditionally independent of s1 for
instance so this connection is not there
either
all right
um so this is the the basic idea of the
markov property it states that uh the
next state is only dependent on the
current state and the action and the
same applies to the reward
so
if that's not the case
uh we'll observe a system that is called
a partially observable system so it's
not enough the markov property is not
satisfied and it's not enough for us to
determine what the next state is going
to be or what the reward is going to be
given the current state in action
and it seems like a fairly obvious
concept
but very often it's it's
a little bit more complicated than it
appears and i'll ask you a few questions
here so i'll give you some examples and
i would ask you whether this is an
observable system or not fully
observable or not
so here's the first example we have a
simulated robot this is the robot that
you see in the picture here
this is a robot that performs a reaching
task so it tries to get that end
effector that green dot over here to the
goal position that is the red dot over
here
and it's trying to do this um so it gets
a reward one when it gets there and zero
in any other in any other location
and our observation consists of the goal
position as well as the positions and
velocities of all of
all of the joints
so if you could uh please answer in the
chat do you think this is fully
observable or not so just say yes if
it's fully observable or no if you think
otherwise
okay you see lots of vs's
you see some nodes
all right yeah so
the answer is that it's probably fully
observable um
right like we can tell everything about
the about the future given that we know
the position and velocities and the
commands that we're sending to the robot
and given the goal position and the
current uh
position and velocities we should be
able to determine the reward
right let's look at another example
um indiscriminate robotic grasping from
a bend given an overhead image so the
task is for this robot that you see in
the picture to grasp any object
and we'll get a reward one if the object
is grasped or reward zero if it's not
and we only get to see the overhead
image from that monocular rgb camera
[Music]
so again please answer in the chat is it
fully observable or not
no
i don't know
that was anonymous death for some no
okay everybody's answering no
yes great perfect and one of the reasons
for it is for instance uh we can't tell
what's the distribution of the weight or
how heavy the objects are so it's
possible that even though we get to see
exact same observations from
we get to see the two
very they basically the same images they
might consist of very different objects
depending on the weight distributions of
them that we don't get to see
um that we don't get to observe in that
setup
all right so one last example and this
is actually an example from the real
world from a project that we work on at
google
which is a robot that is trying to sort
trash
right so this is the robot that you can
see in the in the image you can see
three bins in front of it there's
recyclables compost and landfill
uh we you can assume that the in the in
the camera wherever you stand you can
see all of the vents at once and all of
everything is reachable
and so the robot starts with some trash
in the bins and then it has to source
them it has to store them correctly
right so it gets a reward one if at the
end of the episode
the object that was previously unsorted
is now correctly sorted is this an
observable
environment or not so is it a fully
observable environment please answering
the channel
no
okay we see quite a few no's
so this is a very similar environment
that we have due to what we had before
so let's just eliminate the reason that
we that we used previously so let's just
say that we don't really care about the
distribution of weight and let's assume
that this is not that big of a problem
is there something else about this
problem that makes it even less
observable
anybody has any idea please raise your
hand
occlusion yes occlusions are possible
yeah so there's one other reason
um accurate pose unknown right i guess
this is the pose of the object
you can't necessarily define materials
okay so it might not be clear whether
it's a compostable object or not yeah
these are all great reasons
so one reason that we actually realized
uh quite recently which was quite tricky
is that given an image of a robot
holding an object above the bend that
it's supposed to go to
it's not clear whether
you're about to get a reward one because
you're about to sort that object
correctly or whether you unsorted it in
the first place so it was already in the
correct bin at the very beginning and
you're about to drop drop it into the
same bin in which case you will get a
reward zero so from that state alone
it's not really possible to tell
and this is actually one of the big
problems that that contributed to making
this this problem quite challenging
all right so as we can tell partial
observably can be quite quite tricky
sometimes to determine
um so but let's go back to the goal of
reinforcement learning so we talked a
little bit about the transition dynamics
and markov property
the goal that we are trying to optimize
is in the stationary in the infinite
horizon case we have some stationary
state and action distribution and we're
trying to maximize
the expected reward in that environment
so we're trying to find the arc max of
our policy of the parameters of our
policy theta that will maximize the and
the expected reward
or in the finite horizon case we are
trying to find an r max and optimize the
sum of the rewards from time step one to
time step t
um of all the of all the expected
rewards that are coming in the future
all right so we know a little bit about
the reinforcement learning setting um so
we talk that this course is a lot about
multi-task learning so what's a
reinforcement learning task
so in supervised learning if you if you
recall
a task was defined by data generating
distribution so p of x and p of y given
x as well as the loss
in reinforcement learning a task will be
defined by a few more terms
so first a task will consist of a state
space so these are all the states that
we can enter
the action space so all the actions that
we could take
the initial state distribution
the dynamics
so probability of s prime given s comma
a as well as the reward function
and it's important to to note here that
all of these define the markov decision
process and this is much more than just
a semantic meaning of a task so you can
have a task that semantically means
or you can have two different tasks that
are doing semantically the same thing
but they're still considered different
tasks in the reinforcement learning
sense
all right so let's go through some
examples of task distributions
so um for example in character animation
we can have different tasks where we try
to learn different maneuvers so for
example we can have this little stick
figure that is trying to learn how to
spin kick how to hard wheel how to run
in backflip
and in this case the reward function
would vary across these tasks
we can also do a character animation
where the character that is that is
shown in the picture is trying to put on
a share
and here the shirts may vary as well as
the initial states so the initial state
distribution may vary we might start
with a different shirt or the shirt
might be partly on already and the
dynamics will vary quite a bit as well
depending on which shirt you're trying
to put on so these are different tasks
even though the reward is the same we
only get a reward when when the shared
is on
but the dynamics and the initial state
distributions will vary
another example would be multi-robot
reinforcement learning here we have
three different robots
so here the state the state space will
be different for all of them the action
space will be different as well the
initial state distribution too as well
as the transition dynamics even though
we can be all of them can be trying to
perform the same tasks
all right great so we talked a little
bit about what is a task in
reinforcement learning view
but we can actually have an alternative
view
we can augment our state a little bit
and we can
we we here we'll denote as bar as the
original state that we had
and uh we can add an a task identifier
to that state so we'll just append that
to the to our state vector the task
identifier called z i which tells us
that we're in task i
so this is the original state and we
augmented a little bit
so in this case
the
the task that was originally defined
like this uh the multi-task setup could
be defined as a single task so in this
case the that task would be defined by
all of the tab the union of all of the
tasks that we are considering so
uh in terms of the state space the state
space of that new multi-task task will
consist of the union of all the state
spaces of all the tasks
the union of all the action spaces
the mixture of the initial state
distribution for all of the tasks
the transition dynamics and the reward
so there's an alternative view where a
multitasker enforcement learning problem
is still a one markup decision process
all right so
um
in terms of the goal of multi-task
reinforcement learning it will look
exactly the same as before except we
will augment our state with this task
identifier zi
and that zi could be many different
things so it could be a one hot task id
tells you which task you're in
it could be a language description
or it could be a desired goal state so
for example an image of what you're
trying what what i want you to achieve
in this case the desired that the goal
state would be corresponding to a state
that we want to reach sg
and this will be referring to as goal
conditional rail which is a special case
of multitask reinforcement problem
um what could be a reward in in that
case so it could be exactly the same as
before depending on the task we'll be
getting different rewards or for goal
conditional rel we could the reward
could be a distance function that tells
us the distance between our current
state as bar and the goal state as g
right and we're trying to to minimize
the distance so the reward will be the
negative distance
um there could be different distance
functions that we can use for this such
as the euclidean distance or a sparse
reward um so you only get the reward
when you match the state exactly
otherwise you get zero but we'll talk
about this a little bit more later too
all right so one question you can ask is
if it's still a standard mdp a markov
decision process then why can't we just
apply standard rl algorithms
and the the answer to this is yes you
can you totally can
but very often we can do much better
than that and that's what we'll learn
about in this course
all right so are there any questions
about the multitask reinforcement
learning problem
i have one
quick question to be easy to answer so
is the main
point you're making with adding z sub i
to this state that
in a single task rl problem
this would just be trivially like
part of the context of the overall
problem but you this gives you adding
the
z sub i you have a way to sort of embed
many tasks in some slightly higher
dimensional state space and you're going
to talk about
how to solve this problem non-trivially
that you know by methods other than
using url
right so zi yes i think that's uh that's
the correct intuition zi just makes the
entire and entire mdp observable again
it basically tells you which task you're
in currently and regardless how it's
represented even if it's one hot or gold
image or something else it disambiguates
fully which task you're trying to do
um
and that's what what allows you to to
cast it as a single mdp as a simple
as a single uh reinforcement learning
problem
um
[Music]
all right there's another question if
the tasks don't belong to the same
environment then can we still consider
under the same mdp yeah that's a really
good question
um
so
um i think usually we wouldn't do that i
think we can still consider them as
separate mdps but it is possible to
phrase them as a single mdp as well
where we just consider the transition
dynamics of the union of all of the
dynamics of both environments and the
same with applies to the state space and
the action space
all right great
sorry one more question
what's the significance of
your distinction between the optimality
variable and the reward is that easy to
answer why there's a difference there
yeah so this is this is a little more
tricky and we'll talk about it in two
weeks i think we'll have a full lecture
on that
cool
right
um all right so we uh specify the
problem let's look a little bit at ways
to solve it um so we'll talk about the
policy gradient method
and how we can change it to be a
multi-task method and how it works
so to start i would like to tell you a
little bit about the anatomy of any
reinforcement learning algorithm and
they usually consist of three stages
there is a stage where we generate
samples we can do this by for example
running our policy there's a stage where
we try to fit the model to estimate the
return and the stage where we improve
the policy
and different algorithms would implement
these boxes in different ways
so for example to fit a model to
estimate the return what policy
gradients would do it would just sum all
of the
of the rewards that you got in the in
the current rollout this is
also referred to as monte carlo
estimation
the
different q learning methods would allow
you to what would try to fit a q
function to your returns and this would
be something that would um that would
represent the future returns
and model based methods would try to
estimate the transition probability of p
f p of s prime given s comma a
then in terms of improving the policies
but the policy the policy grading method
would try to optimize the objective that
we care about directly and apply the
gradient to it and we'll learn about it
in a second
q learning methods would try to
maximize the q functions that was
already learned so find the action that
maximizes it and that's the action that
you would want to perform
and for model based methods one thing
you can do is for example back propagate
through the model and optimize directly
for the policy
so in this lecture we'll focus mostly on
modern free url methods such as policy
grading and q learning and you'll learn
more about model-based rl methods
i think in the next lecture or maybe the
one after that
all right so before we talk about policy
gradients i would like to bring up one
more concept which is the on policy
versus off policy reinforcement learning
so in the on-policy reinforcement
learning
the important distinction is that the
data that we are training on comes from
our current policy so we can only use
our current policy to do to do rollouts
to actually see how they work and then
we can use that data to update our
policy
on policy data is compatible with pretty
much all reinforcement learning
algorithms
and it also means that we can't reuse
data from previous policies
so you can only use data from the policy
that you're currently learning that's
why it's on policy or learning on the
policy that you're actually executing
for off policy algorithms the data can
come from any policy it actually doesn't
even have to come from a policy at all
it can be some data that was collected
by humans or
by some
by some engine engineered script or
something like that
it only works with specific url
algorithms and we'll learn about that
too
and it can be much more sample efficient
because now we can reuse all of the old
data as well we don't only we are not
restricted to the data that we currently
see but we can use data from other tasks
or older data
all right so in this part of the lecture
we'll be talking about policy gradients
and in policy gradients we'll be staying
on policy so we'll be only using the
data that comes from the current policy
all right so
policy gradients try to directly
optimize the objective that we care
about so
the objective that we care about uh
which we talked about just a few minutes
ago is the expected sum of rewards
right so this is depicted here we are
trying to find the arc max of that where
we are trying to optimize the parameters
theta of our policy
and one term that might be a little um
unfamiliar to you is this term right
here the tau
and that tau
is nothing else in the
let's just write it right here p of
theta of tau
is
the joint probability distribution of
all the states and actions which can be
then factored as
plus this probability of the initial
state
times our policy pi theta
of the
action a1 given state s1
times the transition probability p of
s2
given
s1
a1
times
the policy
pi theta of a2 given
s2
and so on
and that at the end results in a joint
um
probability distribution of actions and
of all the actions in all the states so
you're trying to take the expectation
under that trajectory distribution that
is dependent on our parameter theta this
is the parameters of our policy they
influence what kind of trajectories
we'll see and for trying to maximize
under that expectation the sum of
rewards
all right so we'll refer to that
objective as j of theta
right so the objective is j of theta
so we're just rewriting this here again
and because this is an expectation under
trajectories what we can do is we can
approximate it with samples
so what that would look in the real
world was we would
take our current policy
roll it out so just run it a bunch of
times and generate a few trajectories
for example free trajectories like that
and then we'll get rewards for these
trajectories so let's say the top
projector will get the top reward the
middle one will get some medium reward
and that one at the bottom will get zero
reward
now to evaluate our objective we can
just sum over samples from our policy
so we can sum all the rewards for each
one of the trajectories and then do an
average across all of these trajectories
this is just to evaluate the objective
so now given the policy we can fairly
easily say how good it is
all right so now that we know
um
how to evaluate it let's try to see if
we can improve it
what can we do to actually directly
improve our policy
so we have our objective
j theta
and here we'll do a little shortcutting
notation where we'll say that r of tau
is um is equal to the sum of all the
rewards that we'll get in the trajectory
so because tau corresponds to the
trajectory r of tau will be the the full
return that we get the sum of all the
rewards for that trajectory
all right since we are taking the
expectation under tau
we can write that expectation as the
integral of pi theta tau r of tau d tau
which would mean that would need to
integrate over all the taus all the
potential trajectories
so now let's try to take a gradient with
respect to that objective
so the gradient if we just apply
directly would look something like that
we have an integral of the gradient with
respect to theta of our pi theta r
pi theta of tau r of tau d tau and that
would mean that we need to integrate
over all the trajectories which is
completely intractable
right so this is a very tricky objective
but
there's a single identity that is called
that is often referred to as a log track
that turns out to be very useful here
so let's try to derive this real quick
so
let's write the following
gradient with respect to x
of logarithm
of f of x
let's just try to estimate what the
gradient is i just kind of made it up
and let's see where we get from there
so this would be equal to
1 over
f of x
this is just the gradient of the
logarithm
times the inner gradient which would be
the original respect to x
of f of x
right i just took that gradient
so now what we can do
we can multiply both sides by f of x
we will get something like that
we would get so the right side i'll just
then i'll write
on the left side right now so we'll get
grad x f of x
will be equal to we just multiply both
sides by f of x would be equal to
f of x
times
grad x
log
f of x
all right so
you have that little identity right here
and
you can see and this is that we didn't
even talk about reinforcement here here
we are just trying to show a
mathematical proof
and this says that
that this has some familiar terms so we
have this
uh let me just change the color
um
[Music]
we have
a term right
looks very similar the term
right here
so i also put this identity here in the
slide so that you can see it in the in
the pdf that is that is on the website
and this is the observation that we just
made so the gradient of f of x or the
gradient of pi theta is the same
gradient that we see right here
so let's just replace it with the
identity that we just derived
so here just our f of x right here got
transformed into
pi
theta of 10.
right so instead of x as a tau and
instead of f it's a pi theta
right so we just replace that according
to that identity
and now we have an equation that can be
actually rephrased as an expectation
again
so now because we have an integral over
d theta
over d sorry over our trajectories and
so detail um
and
inside that integral we have the term
called uh pi theta of tau we can say
that this is the expectation under under
the trajectory distribution tab
of radlock pi times r tau part of tab
all right so
we so far we
said that we are trying to optimize that
objective j of theta the objective is
fairly easy to evaluate it's right here
and if we want to take the gradient of
respect to it we can do it by doing that
expectation and evaluating that term
under that expectation
all right so you can see that there's a
lot of towels in here so let's bring
back the definition of what tao is and
see how it actually corresponds to our
actual policy
all right so we have our pi of
pi tau of
pi theta of tau is equal to this
and uh this is the distribution of all
our states and actions and this factors
as the initial state distribution
um
and uh
times the policy plus uh times the the
transition dynamics yes well there's a
question can you explain how does this
trick solve the tractability problem yes
we'll get to it in just a second
all right so we have our pi tau pi theta
of tau
now if we take the logarithm on both
sides
we see that something like this happens
we have our log pi
theta of tau
and now we just replace all the
multiplications using the the fact that
the logarithm of a product is the sum of
the logarithms and we we end up with a
with an equation like that
and now you can see that
we can replace the log of pi
theta of tau with the
with the equation that we just derived
right here
so let's do that let's swap that in
so if we do this we can now see that it
has all the familiar terms we have the
initial state distribution we have the
policy distribution then we have the
transition
the the the model of the transition
and we have to take gradient with
respect to theta of the entire thing
this is the gradient that comes from
here
all right so now if we take the gradient
with respect to theta the initial state
distribution does not depend theta this
is not something that we can control
that's
that's given to us as part of the task
so the gradient with respect to theta
would be zero
and the same is true for the transition
dynamics so we don't get to control this
this is not dependent on our policy so
the grading with respect to parameters
of the policy theta would be zero
all right so what we end up with is then
something that looks like that this is
just basically crossing out the terms
and putting everything together
um the gradient respect to our objective
is equal and expo is equal to an
expectation number under our trajectory
distribution tau
of the sum over um
grad log pi
and the sum times the sum of all the
rewards
all right
cool so we derived our gradient that we
can actually apply to try to make our
policy better
so now there is a question how does this
solve the tractability problem
so basically this question can be
translated to how can we evaluate that
policy greater than easily
so you can recall that we can evaluate
the objective fairly easily
by approximating the expectation of our
trajectories by just samples over these
trajectories right
so remember that that picture that we
talked about where we have three
different trajectories and we can just
average across the samples
so we can apply exact same trick right
here as well we have the exact same
expectation this is expectation under
the trajectory distribution tab
and we can take the the average so we
can basically sample
uh our policy get our trajectories and
then average across the samples
right so if we do that then now we don't
really have to take that integral that
was so intractable we can just
approximate our expectation of samples
which is what we do very very often in
machine learning um and now all of the
other terms are actually very easy to
evaluate for us we know what log of pi
is this would be the logarithm of the
output of our policy
and we can also sum all the rewards
so now if we wanted to actually make it
into into an algorithm
we could just take that gradient and
apply a gradient ascend algorithm to it
and improve our policy this way
so now if we go back to our little uh
diagram of how
uh
reinforcement learning algorithms work
we generate samples
right here uh let me switch to the
pointer generate samples right here this
is the approximation of the expectation
of samples so this is our uh orange box
we fit the model to estimate the return
right here so in this case this is just
the monte carlo estimation of our
returns we just sum all the returns we
actually got from the trajectories
and to improve the policy we do the
gradient ascend procedure where we are
applying the gradient that we can
evaluate we we know how to evaluate it
right here
and we apply it um to our uh policy
parameters and because of that we can
get a better and better pulse
right so all of these things if we put
them together we can implement a fairly
straightforward algorithm called
reinforce
and this is kind of the basic policy
grading algorithm
the way it works is as follows we sample
a bunch of trajectories from our current
policy by just running it so we produce
the trajectories
then we evaluate our gradient
so we basically do the equation that we
just talked about right here
and then we apply that gradient to our
parameters using the gradient ascend
procedure
and we keep doing that over and over
again so we apply that gradient we get a
policy that is a little bit better and
we sample from the policy and
do this it rapidly over and over until
the policy gets better
all right
so there's one interesting fact about
this entire procedure which is that it's
actually fairly similar to a maximum
likelihood model that you would use for
imitation learning
so if you recall that little example
that we had with drivers where we were
collecting
states and observe states and actions
and collecting training data set and
doing supervised learning on it to get
our policy
the objectives that you would actually
try to optimize to to achieve that would
be a maximum likelihood objective that
is well known from a standard supervised
learning
uh there is a question where represents
the multidisciplinary force so we'll
talk a little bit about the multitask in
one second
so
um
you can see that um
[Music]
the imitation learning
objective would look like a maximum
likelihood objective that is right here
right this is just maximum likelihood of
our actions that were
overtaken by humans
and uh the policy gradient objective is
actually extremely similar if you look
at it
so the first term right here
is pretty much exactly the same so these
are the samples from our current policy
and these are the samples from the
trajectories that we got from the humans
but we have this multiplication
this additional in
multiplication that multiplies it by the
sum of the rewards
and that means a few things so first
that means that we can make these two
algorithms completely equivalent
if we set a reward function to a very
specific reward function that says that
every time you succeed at something you
will get a reward the sum of rewards one
and if you fail at something the sum of
rewards would be zero
then both of these algorithms look
exactly the same
it would just mean that you would have
to do imitation learning on your current
policy on your current rollouts
update your policy according to it and
then do rollouts again update the policy
using only the positives and so on
the other fact the the other thing to
notice is that because this objective is
so similar to a supervised learning
objective
actually all of the things that you
learn about multi-task learning
algorithms can be readily applied here
too so everything that you learn about
multitask supervised learning can be
very very easily used in this setting as
well
all right so a little recap of what just
happened
so
we derived a way to approximate the
gradient with respect to our objective
um and we show that it's very similar to
maximum likelihood so what does that
actually mean in practice so if you you
know if you didn't pay attention and you
didn't follow all the math what what
does this algorithm actually do so what
it does is the following we roll out a
bunch of trajectories according to our
current policy you can see them in here
let's say three different trajectories
and they get different rewards so we sum
the rewards for each one of these
trajectories and what policy gradient is
trying to do is trying to make uh uh the
trying to shift the the distribution of
our policy to make the good stuff the
stuff that got really high reward more
likely and the bad stuff less likely
so basically if you got a high reward
we'll maximize that like that likelihood
of those actions
and the bad stuff will make it less
likely we'll maximize less
and if the reward was zero we won't do
it we won't do anything with it because
if you multiply
if this is equal to zero that sum over
rewards then the gradient will be equal
to zero as well so if you didn't succeed
if you didn't get any reward for the
current task or for the for the current
rollout uh you want that one contribute
to the gradient
so basically that entire policy gradient
procedure simply formalizes the notion
of trial and error we'll try some stuff
and then we'll increase the probability
of good stuff and reduce the probability
of bad stuff
and this is what reinforced algorithm
does
all right so to summarize the policy
grading procedure
um we we now have to take the grade with
respect to the objective and there's a
few pros of policy gradients first is
very simple so you can easily combine
them with with existing multitask and
meta rela and meta learning algorithms
there's also quite a few cons
so first the gradient that we produce
right here
is a gradient of quite high variance
all right so
um
this the reason for this is there's
multiple reasons but one of the reasons
is that
that that reward here uh could vary from
trajectory to trajectory and you would
need a lot of um a lot of rollouts to
actually estimate
um the the entire um
expectation here
so there's a few ways to to deal with
this for example uh usually in practice
people subtract a state dependent
baseline from this
this is a very common way to kind of
subtract from the magnitude of those
rewards so that it's a little bit more
normalized and the variances
is not as high for the gradient
and this is what is usually used by
all algorithms in practice
the other con is that it requires on
policy data
so in particular if you look under this
expectation here you see that the
expectations under the trajectory
distribution that comes from our current
policy uh pi pi theta of
tau so we cannot really reuse existing
experience to estimate the gradient this
is a strict on policy algorithm
there are some ways to deal with this by
using for example important weighting
but this comes with its own set of
problems and produces high variance
gradients as well
all right so that was quite a bit
um
can
are there any questions regarding
policy gradients
as a as a way to solve a reinforcement
learning task
and we don't have that much time left so
i will maybe take one question
i see that chelsea reply to some of them
so that that's really good all right so
given that maybe let's just move on
because we don't have that much time
all right so um let's talk about q
learning
um so q learning could be an example of
an off policy algorithm that would allow
us to use all kinds of data not only
data.com
um
but there's one question is it true that
reinforce doesn't encourage exploration
yes that is one of the that is one of
the problems and there's ways that
people deal with that by for example uh
adding an entropy term to the rewards
such that um you not only try to get to
the to the best solution that you all
know but you also try to be diverse
or sometimes people introduce other
tricks such as epsilon greedy and so on
all right so killer now so it's an off
policy algorithm so we can use data from
that comes from many different policies
and many different tasks um and we'll
start with some definitions
um so first we we start with a
definition of a value function i hope
that this is a review for most of you so
we won't go into into a lot of details
but the value function v pi of the of st
describes the total reward starting from
the current state and following the
policy pi right so it tries to answer
the question how good is the current
state
we also have a q function q pi of sd
comma 18
which tries to describe the total reward
starting from s
assuming that you take an action a at
the current step and then you follow the
policy pi from then on
and that tries to answer the question
how good is a state action pair
right both of these are related and
they're related quite closely so if you
take the expectation with respect to
your current policy pi
of the q function you'll it will result
in the value function v pi of
s and the other thing is that if you
know your your q function q pi you also
you can also use it to improve your
current policy and you can improve it
fairly easily if you just set the policy
to always pick the action that is the
arc max of your current q function so
the action that maximizes the queue will
be the action that you would want to
pick and this way the policy will be at
least as good as the odd policy
all right one other really important
equation is bellman equation which uh
describes how this works for the optimal
policy so we have q star now where star
means that this is for the policy that
is optimal
and q star is equal to expectation over
on
under the next state of the current
reward times the maximum of the q star
of the next state in action
where we take the max over the actions
right so this is the belmont equation
and we can use it to perform q learning
all right
um so i think most of these are probably
familiar to you but we'll go through a
quick quiz to kind of make sure that you
understand these concepts so let's say
that we have a little stick figure
and that stick figure is drumming of
being of is dreaming of being a drummer
right
so um the reward that it's trying to
optimize is that there is a test coming
up in a month from now and in that test
it would need to learn how to play um
these notes
this sheet of notes
and it will get a reward equal to one if
it can play it in a month or zero
otherwise
so this is its reward functions
its actions are as following
action one is that it can just relax and
don't do anything
action two is that it can watch videos
of people playing drums
and try to learn from that
and action three is uh actually practice
drops
the current policy of our stick figure
is uh to
um always take action one
right so the probability of action one
given the current state is always one
all right so here are a few questions so
please answer in chat what's the value
function v pi of sd
right lots of zeros
all right great so a lot of this would
require some kind of estimation of you
know how
um how likely it is that you'll be able
to play drums if you don't practice but
i think we can fairly confidently say
that if you continue with the policy
where uh you don't do anything you won't
be able to play that
to play the drums and and get the reward
equal one okay yes the answer is zero
so what's the q function q pi
of st80 now given that 80 is equal a1
right so assuming that 80 is equal a1
what would be that q function please
answer in the chat
zero yep less of zeros yes it's exactly
the same as the value function
okay great what if you do um what if
it's uh the q function q pi st and a t
is equal a2
what would that be so that would require
a little bit of an estimate please
answering the chat
so that would correspond to a behavior
where you watch a video of someone
playing drums once
and
after that you will just continue
relaxing and not doing anything
okay it's probably a little bit higher
than zero but probably still very very
low yeah there's some answers 0.01 or
something like that
what about if 80 is equal a3 so you
practice drums once at the current time
steps and then after that you continue
your current policy pi it will be
probably okay yes it will be something
like 0.02 it will be a little bit higher
but still not that high
what about q star
so what about q star
if the if a t is equal a1
please answer in the chat
right we didn't really
really see any answer 0.9
okay it depends how talented stick
figure is all right yeah it's a really
good answer
um
so it will be probably something really
close to one right because that means
that just in the current time step you
will relax but from
the times of all during the days after
that you will always be practicing
right
and then the value function will be
equal to one because that means that you
will be just always practicing and
probably the or we hope that the reward
will be then equal to one
all right so this is just a little
example that uh that show us how these
value functions and q functions would
work in practice
um all right so uh let's look at the
quickly on an algorithm that we could
implement to actually
do q learning in practice so this is
called the fit of q iteration algorithm
and it will work like this we will
collect the data set of states actions
next states and rewards using some
policy it can be any policy this is an
off policy algorithm
then we'll set our targets to according
to the bellman equation to the reward
plus the max of the next q function
and then we'll try to fit our q function
to these targets
right and we can use for example an mse
loss to try to do that
all right and we have our parameters
phi here and uh our policy will be or
our q function will be parameterized by
a neural network whereas input it takes
states and actions and outputs a q value
uh one way to do this in a discrete
action space is actually have multiple
heads that where each head corresponds
to a different action
right we'll take number of gradient
steps s and we'll perform it over k
iterations so we'll just collect the
data set estimate the queue targets then
try to fit our q function to these q
targets and then keep doing that
all right then we we can learn the q
function from that
and
as a result once we have the q function
we can get a policy from it fairly
easily and that will just correspond to
taking an arc max over our current q
function to find the action that
maximizes it and that action will be the
action that that we should take and this
would be our pause
all right a few important notes here so
first we can reuse data from previous
policies so we can use any policy to
collect the data and it should still
improve our q function
it's an off policy algorithm
and people usually in practice use
replay buffers to replay the data that
was that was stored by many different
policies
and uh important note here that this is
not a gradient descent algorithm right
this is a dynamic programming algorithm
and then we are doing and the great the
gradient descent in addition to this to
just fit our q function to q targets
this can be easily extended to multitask
and goal conditional rl settings but not
as easily to meta learning settings and
we'll talk about it in next lectures too
all right so i want to give you one more
example of how this could work in
practice and how we actually use it at
google but i have to go over this really
quickly
because we're running out of time so
um
we let's just look at how we can apply
this to robotics and we saw that these
targets
required a maximum of the q function and
the maximum was taken over actions
now if the actions are continuous which
is the case in robotics this can be
quite tricky
so one way we can do this is to use a
simple stochastic optimization algorithm
called cross entropy method and it works
as follows
you would start with the current
position of where the robot is and you
will
fit you'll start with a normal
distribution of mean zero and some
standard deviation
and then you will just sample from the
distribution and you would evaluate um
you will ask the q function how big how
good are the actions from that
distribution so you'll sample a bunch of
actions and then you'll query your q
function about it
then the q functions will give you uh
will tell you that some actions are a
little bit better than others and these
are here depicted in gray so this one is
a little bit better this one and so on
and then you would compute the new mean
and standard deviation of the best
actions so
right here and then you can do this
procedure again
and if you keep doing that you can
sometimes even do it just for one or two
iterations you will get more or less the
maximum of the q function
all right so let's do that
and this was applied to uh the algorithm
called qt opt where q learning was
applied at scale and this was done at
google um where this was done in a fully
distributed setup uh and applied to the
problem
of grasping in robotics
so we will start with with the data that
will start from uh all the past
experiments
we'll have some buffers that we use for
the data that was that was collected
previously as well as the data that is
coming from the robots right now
then we'll represent our q function by
neural network
and we'll have separate processes that
will do the bellman update so they'll
just compute the target that we would
want to fit our q function to
this will use the cm optimization that
we just talked about
after it's done after done on updaters
are done they will just set the a set of
tuples with the queue targets as well as
the current state in action and this
will be then used to actually um to do
the the mean squeeze mean squared error
and update our q function
so we'll have a bunch of training jobs
that are running in gpus or tpus or
something like that
and
they can be updating the parameters
all right so we have the algorithm now
the problems we're trying to apply this
to is something like this
we have a state that is that is just a
camera image over the shoulder which is
similar to the example we discussed
before so this is a not fully observable
setting but in this case it was good
enough
the action is a four degree the third
degree of freedom post changing the
cartesian space plus the gripper control
so we can also close and open the
grouper
and the reward will be binary at the end
so if the object was lifted you get
reward one and uh if it wasn't you get
reward zero
all right some some results from it so
first there were seven robots that were
collecting data over the course of a few
months and it collected
uh 580 000 grasps
and we're evaluating things in unseen
test objects so these objects were not
used
during training and was able to grasp
them with 96 96
test success rate so basically really
really good
it was also able to learn some behaviors
that were not really in the training set
that were necessary to grasp new objects
so this is for example a little
construction where you first need to
singulate the objects and then you you
can grasp them so it learned how to do
that as well
it is also able to to grasp um objects
such as that such as that little ball
and you can mess with it a little bit
and it's a closed loop behavior so it's
uh it's able to uh track that ball and
get back to it and try to grasp it again
and this is also capable of uh doing uh
autonomous free trials where it's not
able to grasp it and it fails a few
times it will know that it failed and it
will try to do it over and over again
until it gets it right
um all right so to summarize q learning
uh the the big pros is that this is more
sample efficient than on policy methods
we can incorporate off policy data
even including a fully offline setting
where there are no robots or no agents
that are collecting experience
as we are training the policy or the
queue function
and
another important point is that we can
update the policy even if we are done if
we don't see the reward so if you recall
in the policy gradient case if our
reward was equal to zero the gradient
would be equal to zero here it's not
necessarily the case so even if you
don't see the reward that might inform
your q function
and it's relatively easy to paralyze and
this was used by the qt opt
in in the qtf algorithm
in terms of cons this is
it's harder to apply standard metal
learning algorithms because it's a
dynamic programming algorithm not a
gradient and algorithm
and it requires quite a few tricks to
make it more stable and to get it to
work
um another argument that it might be
potentially harder to train a queue
function than to train a policy but that
really depends on the problem
all right so this is a quick review of
how q-learning works
so now i would like to talk a little bit
about multi-task queue learning
and i'll stay a little bit after the
lecture to answer your questions because
we're running out of time
all right so
in terms of multitask url algorithms
we learned so far that we can easily
transform our policy or our state to
include
the task indicator um to win the state
by it and then we can apply it to
multitask rl problems so we can do
exactly the same with q function augment
the state with a z information that
tells us about the task and keep going
and it's analogous analogous to
multitask supervised learning so we can
use all the tricks that we know from
there such as stratified sampling
different weight sharing schemes and so
on
however there is something different
about rl here
and the difference is that here the data
distribution is controlled by the agent
so
the the fact is that in in supervised
learning we had that data set that was
curated and we could sample from it here
we get to decide which task we want to
explore
so one question that comes immediately
to mind is should we in addition to
sharing weights because we are trying to
learn multiple a policy that can do
multiple tasks can we also share data
between different tasks
and uh one little question i have to to
all of you is why are we mentioning this
now why are we talking about data
sharing right now and we'll get back to
this question so think about this a
little bit
all right so first a little example how
we could reuse the data between
different tests so let's pretend that
we're trying to learn a hockey task and
there are two actual tasks one is to uh
to do passing we are trying to pass as
well as possible and another task that's
number two is to shoot goals
now we can train all of these tasks but
both of these tasks we can share ways
between them
but now what happens if we accidentally
perform a good pass when trying to shoot
a goal
right so we just we're trying to show
the goal but it just happened to be that
we that we did a really good pass
so
what one thing we can do is we can store
that experience this is about experience
but in addition to this we can create a
copy of it where we re-label that
experience with another task id so
pretend that this was task two and put
the reward there for task two and store
that as well
so basically it's equivalent to us
saying that this was a plan a plan all
along right so i was trying to shut it i
passed it i was actually trying to pass
it and we'll try to store that
experience as such
and this will refer to as hindsight
re-labeling or hindsight experience
replay per
all right so how would that work in
practice
so we'll collect some data using some
policy
we'll start the data in the replay
buffer
and then we can perform on on the data
we can perform hindsight relabeling
so we can relabel the experience that we
just received
and we can pretend that the last state
was the actual goal that we wanted right
so
here we are changing the reward function
we have
r prime
instead of the original r that we had
and we said that the
r prime is equal to the distance between
the current state and the final state
that we achieve
so we pretend that this was the planning
along and this is this is what we did
here
then we store the relatable data in the
replay buffer
and then we update the policy using the
replay buffer so this is similar to a
standard key learning algorithm except
we can now generate much more data
because we can do the high intensity
labeling procedure
so are there any other relabeling
strategies that we can
think of for example we don't have to
use necessarily just the last state but
we can pretend that any state during the
trajectory could have been our goal
state
and use that as a as a potential
relabeling strategy as well
and if we do this then very often we can
see that exploration challenges are
getting a little bit easier because
we're getting much more experience and
we are getting kind of a curriculum of
tasks that leads us towards the goal
that we wanted to achieve
all right so i asked you uh
uh i think one slide ago why why are we
mentioning this now that the data
sharing concept
and uh with the
with the task of of passing and shooting
goals we could use our experiences and
relabel them and and and if we get to
achieve another task that we weren't
trying to do
uh we can relabel them as such and just
use the successes of these other tasks
and then learn from those as well
so let's consider two other tasks one
task is to close a drawer and another
task so this is the final goal of that
task and another task is to open the
drawers so the final goal of that task
would be the drawer at the bottom where
we
that is fully open
all right so now the question is can we
use episodes from drawer opening tasks
or drawer closing tasks as well
and how does that answer change for q
learning versus policy grading
so
keep please keep in mind that
for these two tasks it's let's just
assume that it's impossible to succeed
at opening drawer when you're trying to
close it
and vice versa as well
so it's not that you can accidentally
achieve
achieve success as we did before in the
hockey example
but here you would rather be using
experiences from opening the drawer task
as something that you should not do when
you're trying to close a drawer
so we are not necessarily using just
our accidental successes that we can we
can uh we can get to when we perform a
certain task but we can also use them as
potential failures
and now how does the answer change uh
for q learning versus policy grading in
the policy grading case because it's an
um on policy algorithm and because of
that specific
equation that we wrote how we estimate
the gradient
if the reward for a given task is zero
that does not contribute to the gradient
the resulting rating from that will be
zero as well
in q learning however if we see a
negative that is even coming from
another task we can still use it and it
can still inform our q function that
that action in that state is not really
good so the skew learning and of policy
learning can allow us to use negatives
as well and inform us how to do things
better by learning what not to do
all right so how can we do multitasker
enforcement and improve relabeling even
if it's not a goal condition setting
it looks very similar except
for
um
hindsight free labeling we'll just
relabel our experience according to some
other task
j
right so we initially were
we were
collecting data for a specific task now
we can pretend that that task
can be relabeled for any other task for
example task j and we'll just overwrite
our reward with r prime instead of
original r where the r prime corresponds
to the our the reward function of task j
so r j
here the question here is uh what kind
of tasks should we choose
and we don't really know how to do this
so one way to do this is to just pick
them randomly and free label to random
tasks
another way is to pick another way is to
pick tasks in which trajectory is more
likely to get high reward and there's
multiple more recent papers that talk
about it that i link here
right one more question is when can we
actually apply this for labeling so
first we need to know
um oh there's a question how do we how
do you get reward for the other task
exactly so first we need to assume that
the reward function is known and and
it's easy to evaluate so we can just
take it take a look at the state and
evaluate it for a different test
we also need to make sure that dynamics
are consistent across goals and tasks
and we need to be using an off policy
algorithm although there are people that
are trying there there are there's
researchers trying to do this also for
on-policy algorithms but it's a little
more tricky
[Music]
all right so i think we're running out
of time so i'll skip the results and
the the other example
but basically today we talked about
multitask screen force monitoring
problem how we can solve it with policy
gradient algorithms
how we can solve it with another family
of algorithms called q-learning that are
of policy algorithms and how we can use
those algorithms to do multitask
q-learning where in addition to sharing
waste we can also share data between the
tasks and we talk a little bit how that
data can be shared across different
tasks
all right so there are many remaining
questions though so first can we use a
modeling multi-task reinforcement
learning what about meta-reinforcement
algorithms we didn't get to talk about
these
can we learn exploration strategies in
addition to learning tasks and what
about hierarchies tasks
and we'll talk about this in the next in
the upcoming lectures
there's also many additional resources i
realized that we went really quickly
over
a very large body of material and it's
it might be difficult to keep up and to
understand everything about policy
grading and especially about learning
because we didn't talk in detail about
it so i encourage you to take a look at
some of the resources that are available
online um as well as the other class at
stanford cs230 34.
um right so uh thank you very much for
your attention and um i'll stick around
for a little bit longer uh if there are
any questions
i have a quick question on the hindsight
relay bling if that's okay no of course
um so the first one you showed um where
you talked about the goal state
can you only replace that is that only
if you like happen to end up in the goal
state for another task i was kind of
confused what was going on with like the
goal states and when you could relabel
that right right i think we went a
little bit quickly over this yes so you
can just take the
the last state that you actually
accomplish in that trajectory
right so our trajectory consists of all
the states that we encountered as well
as the action as that we took and the
very last state that we ended up in
and pretend that this was your original
goal
all right so this is a goal condition
setting so a goal is fully defined by
the state
and you can just say that the reward for
that particular transition uh for that
particular episode assuming that you're
trying to accomplish the state that you
actually ended up in
is maximum so in this case because this
is a negative reward it would be zero so
we're just trying to relabel to the very
final state that we achieved and we're
saying that this is the goal that you
wanted to achieve
because does that make sense
uh i think so yeah thank you
you